- I literally own this dress.
- I was like, this is a Kelly dress.
- I, it is such a Kelly dress.
I've literally already
taped a show in this dress.
- Oh my gosh. We are twins.
- Yup. Yep.
I love this dress. I love the designer.
It's so fun and it's so soft.
- It's so soft.
- It's a little country,
a little rock and roll.
- That's what I was thinking.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, country dress. Yeah.
- I like it. I like it.
So America watch you go
through more than one breakup.
They watched me do that
as well. That's hard.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. So I'm just coming,
I relate, it is a very hard thing
to not only go through a breakup,
but to do it at a
national level is intense.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] So, I mean, how is
dating just horrendous now?
- Well, I did meet my boyfriend
and he's wonderful but...
- [Kelly] Wait. Where were
these people you find?
Of course. Adorable.
- He is so cute.
- (stutters) How do you
find so many people?
Like, how do you do that?
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, no, I have these
girlfriends and I'm like,
how do you just meet someone
out of? Like, how do you?
- I went to the dating app.
- You did?!
- I did it. I-
- Oh. I'm too shy for that.
I'd pick bone collector or something.
Like honestly, I think Dateline
special, I'm afraid of it.
- My mom was so mad at me
when I told her I did it.
She was like, I cannot
believe you did that.
- Well look what you found, he's adorable.
- I know, and I always
say to her, I'm like,
you're obsessed with him
and you wouldn't talk to me
because I joined a dating app
and yeah, I just went on a few dates.
- So wait, on the dating app,
do you disclose like right
off the bat who you are
or do you kind of?
- No, I just, I just
was very vague about it.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- That's kind of cool.
- He had no idea anything about me.
- That's kinda rad then.
- Yeah, but he did,
he was like right before I got.
Okay. Our first date is kind of funny.
Like I had been doing,
I had, had like four other dates before
and none of them were that good,
but I started documenting them
like for my own personal, like self-
- About how bad they were
and funny. (chuckles)
- I would like go to the bathroom,
and then I would document
like, okay, this is just not going well.
Like, I don't know what to do.
I'm going to call my friend.
I'm going to send her the
text or she has to call me and
like do the whole thing.
So did this whole documentation
of that. Put it on YouTube.
Oops. And. (laughing)
- Wait, were these people on there or
did you not say who it was?
- No, no I would go to the bathroom
- Oh, I was like damn,
that's like worse than the
Taylor Swift song. I was
like damn. I was like.
I was like, you just
outed him. I was like.
- No, it was like really fun.
I was like, okay, this is fun.
And it took the pressure
off the dates, you know?
Like it was like, okay,
well I'm going to like
have some fun content,
even if the date's terrible.
- Get something out of it.
- And then I had to do like,
had some work stuff to do
before this date with Adam.
And I just wanted to drink.
Like, I just was like,
I just want to go have a margarita.
- Yeah.
- And I like,
- Why not?
- And I like, bumped the
date up cause I was like,
it's been one of those days. I'm like,
can we like be there in like
30 minutes and get a drink.
I wore, I rode my bike,
rode my bike to the date.
Wore like old raggedy-
- You don't want to drive drunk.
I like you already, you're safety first.
- And wore like this sweatshirt
hoodie, rode my bike there.
Sweating as soon as I got there and I,
I walk up and this man's like gorgeous.
And I was like shoot. So I'm like-
- Let me fix my hoodie.
- And yeah.
He's like dressed so
nice. And I'm like, shoot.
But he's like just a calm,
like calming presence.
Like I was so frazzled as
always. And we just hit it off,
but I still was like dang it.
I really liked doing my
content, and then I can't do it
to this guy. Cause I kinda like him.
- That's cool though.
- And then yeah, we hit it off.
But I just, I think I met
him because I was like,
just going to have fun with it.
- Yeah. You weren't, that's
always. That's my favorite thing
that people say to people they're like,
oh, just stop looking. I'm like
everyone that's like single.
Like all my girlfriends are like,
who's not looking? Like
who's, who's just like,
I'm so flippant about it.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
Like, well, I am not
looking, but like others are,
- Yeah.
- So I am afraid of using dating apps.
Have you ever done the dating app.
- No I haven't, but it sounds
like so much fun. Yes. Yes.
No. No. Maybe.
It's like, you're just
doing that all night long.
Right?
- Yes
- Okay. First of all, do you
get like you get there and
you're like that ain't
you in that picture?
- That happened a few times.
- Yeah. Lies.
- I was like, ah.
- And they just kinda
like say who, it's like,
I feel like people might
be. I've never done it,
but I have friends that do it
in they're like, it's I feel
like people are projecting
who they wish they were.
That's who they're like putting out there.
I love mountain biking and I love like,
you know what I'm saying? It's like,
who really loves to, who
has time to mountain bike?
- Don't know, don't know,
- Who are these people?
- Yeah, yeah.
- Or journaling coffee
shops, get out of here.
Yeah. Who has time for that?
- Yeah.
- Next. This is why I
am not on a dating app.
So wait, your, your book is
called God Bless This Mess.
So how did you come up with that title?
- Oh. Lord, because I
need God to help me with
all the messes that I've
been in, in my life.
- I think it means that you're fun.
I think that's code for you're fun.
- I've had, I've had some fun times, but
that's why I need Lord to bless them now.
I guess kind of like this title
just kept coming up for me
and I actually,
the very first time that I
introduced myself to the world,
I, I didn't say like all
the nice things about me.
I'm like, I'm a mess.
Like that was the first
way. I'm like, Hey,
my name's Hannah, I'm a mess.
And then like kind of
going through all that I'm
going through and like
this discovery of it, like,
God bless this mess. Just
sound first of all, Southern.
And just sounds like me. And it's true.
Like, I mean, if you're
going to go through all the,
you're going to have these
situations that are not great,
you're going to make mistakes.
But I think if you really
see the silver lining and the
blessings in that, and like you know,
your life's going to be a lot
better and you're going to
learn from it, so.
- Absolutely.